hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the need for serum 25
hydroxy vitamin D standardization in
clinical and research laboratories
presented by Christopher cheese samples
he is the coordinator of the vitamin D
standardization program in the NIH
office of dietary supplements
I am largely torrance of lab boots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
use laberd's is a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen
what answer as many of your questions as
enough time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge your window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having the problem this presentation is
educational and that's offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Christopher cheese samples I will now
turn the presentation over to him
very much for your kind introduction
Marjorie I'd like to thank everyone for
taking time to attend this presentation
this webinar builds and expands on the
recent lab roots webinar by dr. Gary
Horowitz to emphasize sa standardization
and how relatively inexpensive assay
standardization procedures can be
incorporated into clinical and research
laboratories in this presentation we'll
discuss a number of different topics
related to assay standardization first
I'd like to say that I have nothing to
disclose from the outline of the
presentation will discuss 25 hydroxy D
the analyte used to assess vitamin D
standardization the problem what's the
problem with 25 hydroxy vitamin D
measurement which led to the development
of the vitamin D standardization program
what does standardization actually mean
especially what does it mean to clinical
laboratories and then most of the
presentation will focus on the vitamin D
standardization program its tools and
methods for achieving standardization
and then finally we'll end up with a
very brief examination of emerging
vitamin D standardization issues which
may impact clinical laboratories in the
near future vitamin D status measurement
is assessed by measuring the
concentration of serum total 25 hydroxy
vitamin D and total 25 hydroxy vitamin B
is the sum of the concentrations of 25
hydroxy d2 and 25 hydroxy d3 where it is
assumed
that both the d2 and d3 forms are of
equal biological value I might emphasize
too that there are that the
concentration of total 25 hydroxy D is
often expressed using two different sets
of Units nanograms per mil and nanomoles
per liter nanograms per mil times 2.5 is
an approximate formula for calculating
the concentration of Nana moles per
liter in the u.s. concentration 25
hydroxy vitamin D is usually reported in
nano grams per mil when you look at the
structural forms of 25 hydroxy vitamin B
on your left and 25 hydroxy vitamin b3
on your right you'll notice that the
molecules are very similar and that it's
only in the side chains
where you see the difference up through
carbon 22 which is the carbon just
before the double bond in the side
change the structures of 25 hydroxy d2
and 25 hydroxy d3 are identical and it's
that identical part of their structure
which is used by manufacturing in
developing antibodies to use in
immunoassays for measuring the
concentration of 25 hydroxy vitamin B
and it's those differences in the
science chain structure which can cause
problems with the measurement of 25
hydroxy vitamin D and what is the
problem the problem that continues to
confound the measurement of 25 hydroxy
vitamin D is assay variation in this
paper published in 2004 by a
distinguished group of vitamin D
researchers from the University of
Wisconsin they showed data where the
same serum samples sent to different
labs and analyzed that the same assays
could end up and producing very
different results it was a conclusion of
their paper that they called for a
national effort to standardize the
measurement of 25 hydroxy vitamin B
let's look at some data which show the
problem with assay variation that
existed in assays to measure 25 hydroxy
D at about the time of the paper by that
I just referred to on the x-axis you
will see the names of a number of
different commercial assays and some
laboratory based assay methods and on
the far right you'll see information on
the all laboratory mean now these data
are from the
2008 vitamin-d external quality
assessment scheme program de coifs for
2008 target values for all the samples
mailed out by de cross at that time add
values assigned to them using the new
NIST reference measurement procedure so
that on the y-axis you'll see the mean
percent bias from the reference
measurement procedure and it goes from
minus 10% to plus 20% and you'll notice
looking at the mean bias for the
different assay platforms for example
the dinosaur and liaison had a mean bias
that year of about minus 6% and the
Roche ash assay had a mean bias and plus
16% the mean bias should be between
minus 5 and minus plus 5% so you can see
that most of the assays the mean bias is
very large and within that mean bias
there's a the confidence limits are
quite warm so that as dr. Horowitz
mentioned in his Act presentation
the biggest problem then and now with
the assays to measure 25 hydroxy D is
the amount of a same variation so what
is laboratory standardization put into
the context of vitamin D a standardized
laboratory measurement of 25 hydroxy
vitamin D is accurate and comparable to
the NIST Ghent University and CDC
reference measurement procedures over
time location and laboratory procedure
now I would like
to emphasize that reference measurement
procedures are a very unique category of
laboratory assays reference measurement
procedures are designated by an
international Authority called the Joint
Committee for traceability in laboratory
medicine currently in the world there
are only three laboratories which have
an assay so accurate and precise to be
designated a reference measurement
procedure and again those in the
laboratories that NIST
Ghent University and the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention just
because your assay is of an LC tandem
mass spec assay does it mean that it has
the accuracy and precision of one of the
our reference measurement procedures and
you along with the commercial assays
will need to standardize your laboratory
based assay using the procedures that
they're going to discuss but before we
do that let's give an example of the
impact that assay standardization can
have shown in this slide our data from
the US National Health and Nutrition
Examination Survey or n Haines for 1988
through 2006 what you see is the mean
concentration in the US for in the light
blue and Hanes
3 which was 1988 to 1994 in the brown
reddish brown next to that is the mean
concentration in the u.s. 2000 one and
two then two thousand three and four and
finally two thousand five and six and if
you look from left to right it looks as
though there's a very clear downward
trend over time in the concentration of
25 hydroxy vitamin D and this worried
policymakers and vitamin D researchers
because they wondered what was going on
in the US which was causing this
tremendous trend downward trend
increasing numbers of individuals with
vitamin D deficiency in the u.s. however
you get a very different picture when
you standardize the data from those four
national surveys now you can see the
bars that means for the different
surveys after standardization and now
you can see that there's no difference
over time in the mean concentration 25
hydroxy vitamin D so that these results
really emphasize the importance of assay
standardization both in the clinical
laboratory and in vitamin D research one
thing that's important to emphasize is
that standardization does not require a
single analytic approach any assay is
potentially able to be standardized to
the reference measurement procedure and
we attempt to work with all assay
manufacturers and with individuals
developing their own laboratory assay to
help them standardize those procedures
so that they are get the same results as
you would with one of the reference
measurement procedures so to go over
what the affects of standardization on
laboratories which are standardized
report the true concentration of 25
hydroxy vitamin B within established
statistical criteria based on the NIST
Ghent University and CDC reference
measurement procedures what
houses then pooling of researcher ebook
results in order to develop
evidence-based guidelines which
hopefully then will need to inform
decision-making by physicians
policymakers and others so let's look at
the current sets of guidelines in the US
for interpreting the concentration of 25
hydroxy be on the left you have those
that were released in 2010 from the
Institute of Medicine then on the right
the guidelines released in 2011 by the
end open society you can see that the
cut points are very different for
example the concentration to define an
individual and as being vitamin D
deficient is only 12 nanograms per mil
on the IOM guidelines but is higher at
less than 20 nanograms per mil in the
endocrine society guidelines it's our
view that a lot of the confusion and
chaos which exists over how to interpret
the concentration of vitamin D rests
with the problem of apse a variation and
the tremendous assay variation which
exists in the research data which were
used to formulate these guidelines so
what is the vitamin D standardisation
program its goal is to promote
laboratory standardization for the
measurement of 25 hydroxy vitamin D to
improve clinical and public health
practice worldwide the vitamin D
standardization program was organized in
2010 by the NIH office of dietary
supplements along with a number
other federal agencies and organizations
and individuals throughout the world the
objectives of the lead ESP arch promote
the standardized measurement of 25
hydroxy D around the world especially in
national nutrition surveys commercial
assets and clinical and research
laboratories as well the vitamin disease
standardisation program has developed a
research program to help increase 25
hydroxy d laboratory and measurement and
to study the distribution of 25 hydroxy
vitamin D values in populations now
let's take a look at some of the
components of the vitamin D
standardization program first let's
start with the reference measurement
system the reference measurement system
includes all the tools that you see that
we use to develop standardization
procedures which we're going to
recommend it consists of the NIST Ghent
University and CDC reference measurement
procedures the NIST standard reference
materials or SRMs performance standards
for evaluating when a routine laboratory
is standardized the CDC vitamin D
standardization certification program
and accuracy based performance testing
or PT which is conducted by the College
of American Pathologists
accuracy based vitamin D survey or a BVD
survey and the vitamin D external
quality assessment scheme or D cross the
cap
a BVD survey and decoys are the only two
performance testing schemes around the
world which have materials with target
values assigned to them using one of the
three reference measurement procedures
so the concentration given to any of the
serum samples in the cap survey and in
B+ are the true concentration of 25
hydroxy vitamin D as measured by the
reference measurement procedures and as
you'll see later this is an important
aspect in our trying to design
cost-effective procedures that
laboratories can use their standardizing
their assays now NIST or I should say
the National Institute for Standards and
Technology has developed a number of
reference measurement procedures as part
of this effort they have a reference
measurement procedure for total 25
hydroxy vitamin B a newly approved
reference measurement procedure for 24
25 dihydroxy vitamin d3 NIST is also
working on a candidate reference
measurement procedure for vitamin D
binding protein and doing research on a
reference measurement procedure for
parathyroid hormone or PTH there are
several basic types of SRMs which NIST
makes and sells they sell calibrating
solutions which can be used to calibrate
assays especially LC ms/ms essays here
you'll see that there have very
concentrated solutions of vitamin 25
hydroxy d3 and 25 hydroxy d2
and including the epimer for 25 hydroxy
d3 in ethanol which can then be diluted
to prepare calibration curves for
anybody interested in obtaining serum
2972 way they should contact dr. mary
Bednarik at nist another SRM which NIST
has developed is one on vitamin D
metabolites in frozen human serum this
contains four different levels with only
one level level 4 which had was
fortified with 3 epi 25 hydroxy d3
otherwise also the other three levels
are endogenous levels from supplemented
donors all four levels have certified
and residents values for 25 hydroxy B to
25 hydroxy d3 2425 die hydroxy vitamin
b3 3 epi 25 hydroxy d3 and of course
total 25 hydroxy d another very Neuse
SRM that NIST has released is contains a
high level of 25 hydroxy d3 in human
serum and again this can the NIST SRMs
and human serum can be used to test your
system to see if you're getting the
white value from your assay if you're
getting the correct concentration of 25
hydroxy be from either your commercial
assay or your laboratory developed
outside now let's turn to the VDS
calibration
certification process which is conducted
by CDC the new name for the program is
the vitamin D standardization
certification program the CDC
calibration certification process is a
very rigorous process for assessing
whether a particular Laboratories assay
for measuring 25 hydroxy vitamin D is
standardized this program is intended
primarily for asking manufacturers and
laboratories which have especially high
volumes for the measurement of total 25
hydroxy D the certification process
takes three steps in or phases in phase
one the calibration and calibration
verification phase the laboratory would
measure 40 single donor serum samples
with assigned target values placed there
using one of the reference measurement
procedures the laboratory would measure
the serum samples in duplicate on two
different days would calculate their
total coefficient of variability or CV
and mean bias and see if that conforms
to the DSP performance criteria they're
shown at the bottom VBS peak performance
criteria are mean bias less than or
equal to five percent and a CV total CV
of less than or equal ten percent if
everything is good then it's clear that
the assay has been calibrated correctly
and if not then the laboratory Ennead x'
to take steps to based on the results to
readjust the current calibration as
needed in
is two through four there are four
challenges which are given quarterly
were ten blind and samples are sent to
each laboratory participating at the end
of the year the results from all four
challenges are pulled together and the
total CV and meme bias is calculated
using criteria and protocols in clsi
protocol EP nine if the mean bias at
that time is less than or equal to 5%
and the CV is less than or equal to 10%
CDC will award you a certificate saying
your laboratory is standardized or
traceable to the three reference
measurement procedures that stamp that
certification lasts for one year and all
the laboratories which have been
certified are identified on the CDC
website so that if you wish to maintain
certification you need to participate in
the CDC program continuously so you can
see that this is a very rigorous program
and also costly for a lab to participate
in so that again it's developed
primarily for assay manufacturers and
for laboratories which have
exceptionally large volumes for
measuring serum 25 hydroxy vitamin D so
let's quickly go through the list of
laboratories which are currently
certified by CDC as standardized and if
you look down the list you'll see a
number of assay manufacturers research
laboratories commercial laboratories
clinical chemistry laboratories
a number of laboratories throughout the
world so what does this mean to you of
the clinical laboratory if you're saying
you're using the IDs Isis system in your
laboratory what does that mean for you
what it means is these that your assay
is potentially standard is not
standardized Abell what that means is
that you and your laboratory have to
follow the directions given to you by
IDs and verify that after following the
directions to calibrate the system you
are getting the true result within those
VD espy performance criteria which we
mentioned just previously and we'll go
over this again as far as how that all
fits together with the steps we want to
suggest to you for standardizing your
measurement of 25 hydroxy vitamin D so
let's now do just that and talk about
standardization of clinical and research
laboratories now and into the future
there are four phases of standardization
which we've identified the first is the
development of the reference measurement
system which we've discussed previously
and which consists consists of the
reference methods the NIST SRMs the
performance standards
the CDC certification program and
accuracy based performance testing or
external quality assessment schemes the
second step is to calibrate commercial
assay system to reference materials and
reference methods the third step is to
calibrate individual clinical and
research laboratories and
or step is to verify and user test
performance step 2 emphasizes the
critical role that commercial assay
systems play in the measurement of 25
hydroxy vitamin D especially in clinical
laboratories so one of the both sides
from the beginning of the VDS pee has
been to work with commercial assay
manufacturers to help them standardize
their systems now let's look more
closely at phase three and in Phase
three what we've done is we've developed
a set of steps that you can use to
calibrate your own laboratories assay so
that is standardized to the NIST Ghent
University and CDC reference measurement
procedures first is to start with your
manufacturers instructions to calibrate
your instruments then to evaluate the
accuracy of that initial calibration if
the initial assessment of accuracy is
not good then you have to go back and
recalibrate your instrument if possible
if it's a commercial assay you may have
to call your as a representative and
have them come in and recalibrate it for
you but once the assay is calibrated you
can proceed to step 3 which assessment
of total CV and mean bias using single
donor serum panels serum materials from
the CDC standardization program or NIST
SRMs
then
you meet the CV and mean bias criteria
set by the BD SP you can then go on to
measure your samples and then at the
same time use NIST SRM materials as
controls to see if you're actually
measuring true concentration and then
finally to verify and use their
performance by participating in the
clinical laboratories primarily the cafe
VD Survey or D cross I would recommend
that all clinical laboratories
participate in one or both of the
accuracy based surveys but let's take
just a second to go back and look at
step number four and the use of truelist
controls and think how can we make the
whole process more inexpensive one way
to make the process much cheaper and
much more affordable with small clinical
and research laboratories is substitute
the use of cap ABV D and D cross samples
for NIST SRM and single donor serum
samples all the way down through the
different steps so that when you come to
step four you can use these cost
effective and minimal cost resources to
go through steps one two three four and
five to standardize your assay in step
four when you're running the patient
samples if you include this SRM or D
crossing
have materials and blind unknowns after
the run you can compare your assets
values to the NIST SRM or to the target
values of the D cross or cap samples and
develop a master equation and see just
how accurate your assay is performing
and if it's not performing accurately
you could use this equation 2 then
recalibrate all of your values is
standardized values and this is often
the problem with the use of commercial
assays because you have so little
control over the assays this post
measurement standardization is often the
only method available to you for making
sure that your measurements are
standardized so I would like to take a
moment now to talk about a flaw in the
performance guidelines that the B DSP
uses that's associated with mean bias
but before we start let's look at an
example you have again in this slide you
show you the performance guidelines
vitamin D standardization program use to
evaluate whether a routine lab it's
standardized or not two criteria again
are a CV less than or equal to 10% an
amine bias less than or equal to 5% and
when let's focus primarily on mean bias
is calculated by subtracting the true
value from the test value dividing that
by the true value so that you get the
percentage difference from the true
value which is and that can be a
positive or negative number and that's
the bias and then let's look at the
results from two different laboratories
laboratory two used in immunoassay
laboratory 16 used an LC ms/ms acid
you'll notice if you look at their total
cv and mean bias results are almost
identical in an absolute sense for both
laboratories in other words the
immunoassay has the same performance
characteristics of the mass spec assay
and if this were participating in the
cdc performance program both
laboratories would be certified but
let's look further at the data first
let's look at this plot this difference
plot of data from laboratory two along
the x-axis you have the reference value
and on the y-axis the percent difference
the bias and in red you have outlined
plus or minus 5% notice how many of the
values from laboratory to have a bias
it's far different from zero
notice the very enormous amount of assay
variation from laboratory to now
look at laboratory 16 again in the
x-axis is the reference value or the
true value and the y axis is the mean
bias you notice the scale is much
narrower here than for laboratory two
and you can see that most of the values
for laboratory 16 are lived in Elser
minus 5% that much less sa variation or
the mass spec acid now when you look at
more recent data from d quartz comparing
was mean bias between 2012 and 2014 this
is the period 2015 to 2017 you'll notice
in the white grey histogram the in large
part the values for these different a
same manufacturers assay the mean bias
is getting closer to zero however even
though the mean bias is in the right
direction
notice the enormous amount of variation
which billing is seen within different
amino acids
compared to lc/ms and HPLC
so that even though we're moving in the
right direction as far as reducing mean
biased towards zero there are still an
enormous amount of variability which
plagues the measurement of 25 hydroxy
vitamin D moreover mean bias misses that
a variability which occurs around the
mean so that vitamin D standardization
program needs to adjust it performance
criteria to add some sort of confidence
limits around mean bias what are some of
the emerging standardization issues that
you'll probably face in the near future
there's a great deal of discussion among
vitamin D researchers as what the
definition of vitamin D status should be
currently as I said before it's
universally accepted that 25 hydroxy
vitamin D is the best marker of vitamin
D status but accumulating data supports
the use of 2425 dihydroxy vitamin D and
it's ratio with 25 hydroxy D as a
measure of vitamin D status in certain
clinical presentations so that
individuals with certain diseases
especially genetic disorders on 25 24 25
hydroxylase for example our indications
where the ratio of 25 hydroxy vitamin D
to 24 25 dihydroxy vitamin D is a very
useful criteria for identifying those
patients and if you see below vitamin D
binding
protein bioavailable or free 25 hydroxy
died vitamin d3 discussions are going on
now as data accumulates should there be
some combination of vitamin D
metabolites used to define vitamin D
status or should we stick with 25
hydroxy vitamin D and should we look
more closely at the relationship of 25
hydroxy vitamin D concentration to the
suppression of pair of vitamin B D of
DSP objectives for the future then our
load assay manufacture participation in
CDC's vitamin D standardization
certification program to reassess and
tighten B DSP performance criteria in
order to promote improved accuracy and
precision we want to promote Clinical
Laboratory participation and accuracy
based performance testing external
quality assessment schemes we want to
work to develop a nick nutritional
rickets registry which can then be used
to define better vitamin D status
related to vitamin D deficiency and
defining vitamin B deficiency and next
we want to promote the standardized
measurement of new vitamin D metabolites
in vitamin D research so that in the
future we don't have this problem of
assay variability clouding the meaning
and interpretation vitamin D research
I'd like to mention that if you're
interested in hearing more about the
vitamin D standardization program we
have a meeting that's going to take
place on November 28th through 30th
there are still seats available for
attending in person or if you wish you
could attend
meeting via webinar final thoughts are
25 hydroxy D is an extremely hard
analyte to measure and to standardize
this will take time to get it right
progress has been made through
collaborations with commercial
commercial assay manufacturers and
laboratories cap and across and with you
members of routine clinical laboratories
and finally we look forward to working
with all of you in the future thank you
very much for your attention
thank you doctor samples for that
informative presentation you'll now
start the live Q&A portion of the web la
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the thread button well
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for let's get started our
first question is should clinical labs
participate in accuracy based
performance testing programs that's an
excellent question Marjorie thank you
very much I believe that it's preferable
for clinical laboratories to participate
in accuracy based testing programs
performance testing programs where the
materials you'll receive have target
values assigned using one of the
reference measurement procedures that
way you're comparing your results
against the true results as assigned to
those samples with one of the reference
measurement procedures if you
participate in a performance testing
external quality assessment scheme
that's not based on accuracy based
they're using sample which have a true
concentration of 25 hydroxy B you never
really know just how accurate or
imprecise your assay is
thank you our next question is how do
you obtain this standard reference
materials and our samples from College
of American Pathologists and vitamin D
external quality assessment scheme to
use its trueness controls excellent
question Marjorie Thank You Marjorie
that that's also an excellent question I
do not know if individual samples are
available from cap and I would urge
laboratories that participate in cap to
contact their representative to see if
samples can be purchased to use as part
of their laboratories estimate to verify
that the accuracy of their systems on
the other hand extra sets of materials
are available from D cross and you can
go to the D cross website and send them
an email and tell them you wish to
purchase additional samples for use of
trueness controls in your laboratory and
also you can remember that if you do
participate in cap and because you can
save the materials that are unused from
your different testing periods and he
saved those properly you can use those
as well to test the accuracy in your
assay systems
thank you our next question is how often
should let's check the standardization
of the assay
that's a very good question and a very
difficult one to answer because small
clinical laboratories are very busy
places where they're testing lots of
different materials so adding in the
assessment of vitamin D accuracy and
standardizing your assay is something
that can only be done periodically at
best if you could run trueness controls
with each batch that would be preferable
but if that's not possible
I would like to suggest that
laboratories standardize their systems
or test whether their systems are
standardized prior to each period of
participation in either cap or D cross
so that prior to measuring the samples
as part of the testing that goes on in D
cross and cap you can standardize your
assay and make sure it's performing as
best it can before submitting your
results
thank you for that answer our next
question is how can I join the vitamin D
standardization program thank you very
much for that question Marjorie that's
one we especially like to hear if the
participants would use the information
on this last slide it gives my email
address and which also gives the the
website for the vitamin D
standardization program at NIH you'll
find information on the website on how
to contact us and become a member of the
VDS P or if you'll just send me an email
I'll make sure that you get put on our
list of participants in the VBS P and
we'll keep you up to date on all
activities of the program
okay it looks like we have time for one
more question our last question is can
you up the slide with the vitamin D
standardization program meeting
registration information
yes but here it is here's the meeting
information for how to see the agenda
the website for the meeting and how to
register make sure that you use the
username VDS P and password when
prompted and those will get you in to
the website for all the information
about the meeting registration is
required to participate either in person
or via webinar so again either you want
to attend the meeting to use this
website to log in using the username BB
SP the password vdf P and then send us
all the information to register thank
you very much for that marker
I would like to once again thank dr.
Christopher T Santos for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
lab cats possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through February of 2018 you order
Steven email from laggards letting you
know when this webcast will be available
for replay make sure that announcements
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's like that that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye